and now these fears are becoming even
more real for the so-called reset
uh wales in the united kingdom is
implementing
something akin to a vaccine passport
from the welsh health minister von
gitting
he says those receiving a covid19
vaccination
will be given a credit card sized
national health service wales
immunization card which will have the
vaccine name
date of immunization and batch number of
each of the doses given
hand written on them
huh what why am i getting an
identification card
to tell me that i've had this vaccine
that has just come out it's not even
available to the public yet
what what i need that for now of course
the health minister here says oh it's
free it's just for your own good it's
just to remind you
he says these these cards will act as a
reminder for the second dose and for the
type of vaccine
it will also give information about how
to report side effects okay well i don't
need to carry a card around to have a
phone number i can just put that on my
phone
uh this comes amid concerns though that
british businesses not even just the
government businesses will start to
require proof of
vaccination as a condition of entering
their businesses
this has been suggested a lot before now
you're going to see a lot of arguments
crop back here because
notice that it won't be the government
leading the mandates for the vaccine
passport
it will be businesses and there will be
some maybe more libertarian-minded
conservatives who will say oh well it's
just business you businesses are free to
do whatever they want as long as it's
not the government
forcing me to take this vaccine and
carry around proof of it all the time as
long as it's not the government it's
totally fine
and you will have conservatives saying
no i don't think so
i don't care if my life is being upended
and my civil rights taken away
and my traditions destroyed and my
society wrecked and my family broken up
i don't care if it's
the government doing that or big
business doing that or anyone else doing
that i don't want that to happen
i don't want to if if i am prevented
from engaging in our society
without this vaccine or a proof of the
vaccine by business
or the government the end result is the
same
and i don't really care the mechanism i
don't really care about the procedure
i don't want that to happen i do not
deny i think i think conservatives
actually go a little bit wrong
when they deny that the government has
the right to make you do extraordinary
things
in the name of emergencies that's what
the police power is for that's how we
had this whole lockdown feusted on us in
the first place because the government
does have the legitimate police power
government has the right to force you to
take a vaccine
for goodness sakes it seems extreme but
there have been court cases to this
effect
so i think we need to stop arguing from
this
abstract perspective and just say
it's rights they have no right to do
this the government's bad business is
good whatever this
abstraction is and get down into the
particulars
i know that that you know that involves
more apprehension or involves more
uncertainty okay that's where battles
are fought and won
that's where life is lived the
government has the right to
certain police powers yeah totally grant
that government even has the right to
force someone to be vaccinated during an
epidemic okay sure
fine i'm not even going to fight that i
don't want this
i don't want the government to force
everybody to take this vaccine
i don't want big business to force
everybody to take this vaccine
i don't want to be required to carry a
vaccine passport
i'm not making an abstract argument
about that i'm making a narrow political
argument
i as far as i can tell we the people
still have some voice in our government
that hasn't totally been taken away
john ossoff who's running for the senate
in georgia espouse the view of the
democrats if they get power which is we
need to take more power away from we the
people
need to give it over to experts who
knows so much better than we know
ourselves
uh-uh not yet i'm not willing to concede
that yet
we still have a right to express the way
that we want to
live in our politics in our society and
i don't want that
i think we need to push back against
that you are starting to see this by the
way
you're seeing business owners push back
against this you're seeing people go out
in the streets
and show up to bars show up to
restaurants
and they're not it's not like blm
they're not going in and you know
peacefully stealing gucci handbags and
nike sneakers
they're going and they want to keep
their businesses open and they want to
frequent their favorite businesses and
they want to see their family and they
want to see
their friends